because I worked at Burger King in Tria
at the main train station and there was
no minimum wage and in 2009 there was a
federal election and Frankwalter
Steinmeier was the candidate for chancellor for the
SPD and was now Federal President and he
said why don't we actually have a
minimum wage in Germany and he did
Tria gave a fiery speech in front of the Port Nikra
for the minimum wage and
it totally got me carried away and I
asked myself, is that right? I'll get
6.13 here and now I've
got a salary increase to 6.18 € and
the minimum wage would be something for me
but also Oleg next to me at the checkout
who somehow has to get his wife and children through with it go go